tell me slow but it just dawned on me
that Laurence Fishburne is in both the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the DC
Cinematic Universe and he's not the
first or only actor to crossover from
Marvel movie to DC movie or vice-versa
but he's in two different yet currently
ongoing rival cinematic universes it's
kind of interesting
[Music]
ant-man and the lost so ant-man and the
wasp is the sequel to ant-man and the
newest movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in this one Scott Lang becomes
ant-man again and Evangeline Lilly has
become the wasp
and they team up because a new situation
needs fixing and an old situation needs
fixer a lot of things happen in this
movie it requires their attention I just
love Paul Rudd as ant-man
you know Paul Rudd just oozes relatable
and flawed character you want to root
for he's the underdog he's a true
underdog in fact this movie just screams
underdog I rely but when I think
superhero Evangeline Lilly wasn't the
name that came to mind it was when she
was in loss but loss was over years ago
and she's back to the superhero but Paul
Rudd and Evangeline Lilly today just
they don't scream superhero to me which
is why they're perfect underdog story
and the movie generally speaking is
really enjoyable the action sequences
are top-notch - and the ant-man movies
have the advantageous position to have
their action scenes involve characters
that are normal-sized like you and me
then they go down to insect size and
that changes the scenario and back to
normal size and bounces back and forth
like that the way the movie plays off
that bounces off that integrates these
two worlds of different size that's a
specifically ant-man scenario for an
ant-man phone in a world where superhero
movies are everywhere you have to play
up the thing that makes your superhero
movie unique me ant-man movies play that
unique quality of well and the action
scenes involve the villain ghost who is
someone who has been affected by the
quantum realm she's facing in and out of
our realm she can go through walls and
matter it's pretty much Rafael's ability
from legacy of kain she just can't
control it old legacy Kane didn't really
involve the quantum realm in fact the
quantum realm which we saw Scott Lang go
to in the first ant-man movies a big
part of this one in that I wish they
would have delved into the quantum realm
more it's like this is an opportunity to
really explore what is it and break it
down for the people at home when they
break it down a bit but they don't
really they don't go any deeper miss
teaching opportunity as far as I said oh
really ant-man and the wasp suffers from
what most Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies suffer from which it has humor
which in and of itself is not a problem
but it has humor that sometimes
compromises the more sentimental moment
and too weak villain there are
exceptions I'm not saying it happens all
the time fan hos was awesome but really
if I had to put my money on it those two
flaws are the flaws that are in a lot of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe movies and
they're in this movie - also
disappointing because ghost has the
opportunity to be a very sympathetic
character as it stands they don't hit it
home as well as they probably thought
they did in fact
18 in general Santos and kill Martin it
looked like Marvel Studios was in the
phase of learning from the past why it's
a little disappointing now after those
two movies in their villain seeing
ant-man and the wasp adieu a bit of a
back step in that department and really
there were too many irons in the fire in
terms of villains or antagonists one you
have ghosts someone who can phase
through matter because of the quantum
realm coming after him then you have the
FBI because Scott Lang is on house
arrest he's not actually supposed to be
out there doing this stuff but he is and
make them think that he's actually still
at home that's an added complication and
you have Walton Goggins who's a criminal
and he's coming after him - that is the
most out of place element in this movie
why is Goggins in this movie why is
there a band of criminals coming out
from they also have to dodge I'll
actually tell you the reason they're in
it because if the car chase sequences
were only comprised of FBI agents you
couldn't do really destructive to
get away from them like that scene right
there you'd be like oh my gosh that
agent is he is he okay did he break his
neck does he have a family
he probably has a family okay just an
agent doing his jobs nothing wrong with
that he's not a villain but you make
them scumbags yeah sure break your neck
no one cares and I feel like that's the
only reason those criminals in
particular we're in this movie I feel
like they would have fit in the movie a
little more maybe they were tied in with
ghosts or something the mid credit
sequence is a great one the very last
end credits scene is actually it was in
the trailer the mid credit post credit
sequences with those are sacred throw
them into the trailer so like it's not
the first movie I feel like there's
another movie I can't think of it right
now but that happens there's in the end
ant-man and the wasp enjoyable movie you
see Easter eggs and some trickle from
events that have happened in the MCU in
the past so really a lot of its really
tied with Hank Pym and his family it's
more personal
it really is Paul Rudd Michael Douglas
and Evangeline Lilly they're weird
family dynamic just carries the movie
that and the action sequence superhero
mechanics elevate this movie to a really
enjoyable film makes you look past some
of the flaws one in particular it kind
of felt like a CW thing where it was
like we don't have to have a good
explanation for it but this thing
happens and you're like I'm not really
sold on the Evangeline Lilly Paul Rudd
romance because I feel like most of it
that Bilt's
built in between the two movies I kind
of talked about it but we didn't say so
when she's pissed at him you don't
really feel like he lost a girlfriend or
anything and she shows affection for him
or she's flirting with him it just kind
of feels out of place like where'd that
come from no in the first movie it was
building a bit there but I just I just
don't buy it
like the first ant-man movie more than a
men in the wasp but still had a really
enjoyable time with this one fact I had
a really good time no alcohol required
funny little side note on the thumbnail
of my ant-man review there's actually a
little meat on my shoulder but I feel
like the picture got so pixelated when
you upload it to YouTube and then the
thumbnail is so small no one caught it
though it is what it is all right so
ant-man and the wasp have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]